ます うん 心の問題について
今日 2回目の話でございます
うん 私たちの心というものは
もう体よりものすごくもろい弱いものなんですね
で その論理は前回で説明いたしましたけど
で 体っていうのはまあいくらか暑さに寒さにいろんな攻撃に耐えられます
残念ながら心っていうのはもうなかなか耐えられませんね
ちょっとしたことでもう大変なもうダメージを受けて壊れてしまうんです
ですから もう大変気をつけて
ものすごく丁寧に気をつけて心を守ってあげなきゃ
まあ生きるということはもうどうしようもなくなっちゃうんです
できなくなるんです ですから
確実に我々は何を守るべきかというと
心を守るべきなんですね
体を守るということはそれほど大事なことじゃないんです
体っていうのは まあただの物質ですから
まあ宇宙の法則によってもうなんとかなるんです
この前も同じ例を申し上げました
例えば怪我しましたと
もう放っておいても治るんです
たとえ細菌なんか入ったっても
もうやがて治るんです
心はそうじゃないんですね
そんな簡単に自然に治ってくることはないんです
すっごくちょっとしたことでも
もう粉々になってバラバラになって
もう大変なことになるんです
で なぜ心をそんなに守るべきかというと
我々は体で生きているわけじゃないんです
心で生きているんですね
心があるんだから私 私と言うんです
別に心がなかったらただの物体ですからね
仏教から見ればただの物体なんですよ
体から心が抜けちゃったら
そのその国でいろんなことを考えているかもしれませんだけど
痛いだけ仏様だと思っているかもしれません
何のこともないんです
ただのゴミなんです ゴミだから
まあ焼却すればいいんです
死んでから それは何ですかというと
この体ではなくて心が抜けちゃったんだから
もう物体になりましたしね
ですから 私はということは心なんですね
心だから生きているんです
法律的な権利も全部心がある時に限るんです
法律でそういう決まってはないんだけど
生きている時だけ 自分の財産の権利はあるのは生きている時だけ
死んだら自分に何の権利もない
この生きているということは
やっぱり心が活動しているということなんですね
皆様にこの前も説明しました
心で命令しなきゃ たとえ手を上げることも
まぶたを閉じることさえもできないんです
たまにこの体っていうのはこの機械みたいにできているんだから
この反射的な働きはあるんだけど
我々は全部反射で生きているわけじゃないんだからね
手を上げる時も 座る時も
歩く時も 喋る時も その意思があって
手を上げたい 喋りたい
話したい 寝たい 起きたい
そういう意思があって行動しているんですね
ですから 生きているということをすべてが心が主人になってやっているんです
でお釈迦様がおっしゃっているように
この世の中支配している主人は誰ですか？と聞かれた時
神様ですよと言ってないんです
この世の中を作って それから管理して
この世の中を運営して
全部やっているのは誰ですか？と聞いたら
お釈迦様はとても簡単にチッてね
ニーヤティローコ ローコっていうのは世界ということで
世の中ということで 人々を生命のことを意味するんですね
だから生命は心に導かれている
心に管理されていると
心に言われるままに生命が生きているんだと
心という唯一なものにすべてが抑えられているんだと
すべての人々が抑えられているんだと言っているんです
ですから 私たちも結局心の奴隷なんですね
心の奴隷 何もあの独立性も
もう自由に生きているとか
何のこともできないんです
ただ心の奴隷 心がこの体を動かしているんです
そういうことは 心という現象は大変大事な現象なんです
西洋的な考え方と比べて言うならば
もう神と同じなんですね
仏教から仏教の人に聞けば
神って何ですかと私に聞けば
私は言うのは心ですよと
心の奴隷でしょうと 心に逆らうことはできないでしょうと
すべて決まっているのは心ではないかと
ですから 仏教では この天国にいる人間に見えない
人間に認識できない すごい超越した何かに我々は作られて守られているかという話は全くない
すごい具体的に我々は心から支配されて
心にまあ言われるように生きているんだと
そのポイントは徹底的に覚えておいてください
我々は心の奴隷であると
難しいことではありませんね
で この話終わったら皆様ご飯召し上がるんですね
で 何を食べたい？食べたいということは心が決まるでしょうに
そばを食べたくなったらそばを食べるし
私はそば食べたいんだからうどんにしましたよという人はいませんしね
で 心が言う通りにするんです
どんなことでも心が に言われたらするんです
例えば 険しい山を登りたかったならば
まあ苦労は考えません
登ってみるんです 心が登れというんだから登っちゃうんです
何か大変な 何か心に気に入った品物があると
別に自分に体には必要ないかもしれません
でも見たら心があれ欲しいなと言ったら
その人は借金でもしてその品物を買ってしまっちゃうんです
そんな心に言われる通りにして
人間っていうのはいろんなもう不幸にもなったりはするんです
例えば会社があると で
社長の心が遊びなさいと言われたら
会社の経営はまあ放っておいて遊ぶんです
そこで会社が倒産して
自分がひどい目に遭うかもしれません
でもそんなことは気にしない
心に言われると何でもするんです
心に逆らうことできる人は一人もいません
人というのは生命が一人もいません
できれば逆らってみてください
絶対できません だから
そのポイントはよく覚えていただきたいんです
それから そんなに偉大なる心
我々はまぶたを閉じることさえコントロールしているんです
まぶたを閉じなさいと
そしたら閉じる この深く瞑想して瞑想体験がある方々は知っているだろうと思いますけど
心臓の鼓動 呼吸も全部コントロールしているんです
ですから 心を落ち着く
落ち着いてもらうと まあ心臓の動く速さがものすごくコントロールできるんです
呼吸は止まってもらうこともできるんです
心は他の仕事をしていると
でも人は死なない それは科学的にはさっぱりわからないかもしれませんだけど
科学的に見れば そんな呼吸止まったら人は死ぬだろうと
人は死ぬのは体から心が抜けた時なんです
それで心がすごい忙しくて
落ち着いて他のところをやっていると
呼吸も止まるんです で
死なない 心臓 すごいゆっくりわからないほど
ただ血液流れるだけで心臓のことは一応わからない
わからないことは心臓止まるんだとかインドで言ってますけど
まあ止まるというのは
まあ鼓動はわからないほど弱くなって
なんとなく血液が循環しているだけで
そこまで心にコントロールできるんです
まあしようとするならば
その私たちのすべてのことをコントロールしている
管理している この心が残念ながらものすごい臆病者で
弱くて脆くて壊れやすくて
どうにもならないもんなんです
だからなんかすごいなんか変なシステムなんです
まあまあ これは具体的な社会的な例で申し上げますと
日本は平和な国だから
なかなか日本からはまあちょっとあの例を出すことは難しいんだけど
例えば ある国に大統領がいるんだと
総理がいるんだとかいうと
その国の一番強い 一番偉い人なんですね
でも その人に限って一番弱い脆いなんですね
買い物できないんで 外へ出て
ちょっとでも自分が住んでいる
そのまあそういう公のね
まあすごいところありますからね
軍隊に守られて警備されて
ああだこうだとか もし
一人で外を出ちゃったら
おそらく命がないんです
誰かに殺されちゃう  自分の国でも大統領がどこか行くんだったら
まあだいたい 3ヶ月間前から警備やるんで
その地方で それだけじゃなくて
だいたい 8 キロ範囲で全部一索するんです
車も全部 知らない人は誰一人も入れないんです
でも 国を管理して 全部独裁的な権限を全部持ってるんです
その人に言われると もうみんなもうそれ法律になって全部やりますけど
一人では外へ出られないんです
出たら終わりと まあ日本にしたっても
そんなにね もうもう大臣たちやらね
そういうとかね どこかにデパで買い物したとかね
どこかでスーパーで弁当買ったとか話は聞きませんだから
ちょっと遊びに出ちゃったら
ちょっとどうなるかわからないかもしれません
日本にしたってもね 天皇陛下とかそういう皇室の方々がどうか出かけると
どれほど警備するかというと
ものすごい厳密に 徹底的に
でも 残念なことに その方こそ一番強くて一番偉いんです
かえって他の反面で もうどうしようもない
すごい弱い ですから 私たちの体の場合も同じこと
心が王様で帝王で神様で全部コントロールしている
命令出している でも ほんのわずかなことでまあ壊れてしまう
ですから まあ社会 複雑な社会を作っていない
まあ動物なんかはいくらか楽にいるんだけど
人間にとってはもう大変なことなんですね
生きているということは
だから健康な心でいる人っていうのは
お釈迦様はいないんだとおっしゃってるんです
精神的な健康な人いません
みんな病気ですと そういうことで
あの 2番目のポイントなんですけど
この偉大なる心っていうのは
まあすごい弱いんだから
徹底的に守ってあげなくちゃいけないんですね
ですから 守るプログラムも我々は心に教えてあげなくちゃいけないんですね
自分を守るプログラム
守るプログラムなかったらもう壊れちゃう
それからなんで人間というか生命というかね
心が弱いかというと 心というのは
まあ随分まあ簡単に言えば大馬鹿者なんですね
何も知恵もないんです
普通の世界では まあ自分の知識やら心について随分自慢しているんだけども
何の知恵もないんです
ただ感情で行動するだけ
何か美味しいと思ったらそれしか見えなくなっちゃうんですね
で 美味しいものをとにかく捕まってみようではないかと
心に聞いてみてください
なんでそれ欲しいんですか？と心に
自分に聞いてみてください
とにかく 例えばあのシャネルのカバン買いたいんだと
もう買わずにいられないでしょ
買いたくなったら じゃあ心に聞いてみてください
何のために？なんで買いたいんですかと
なんで好きですか？と
わかりますか？自分に聞いてみたらわからないでしょうに
私は赤い服が好きですよという人がいるかもしれません
ですから そういう人は赤い色のものはありとあらゆるものを集めたりする
その人に聞いたら なんであなた赤いのこと好きですか？と
人が聞くと嘘を言いますからね
自分で聞くんです そうすると嘘をつけません
ですから 心っていうのはものすごい
まあまあ知識がなくて
ただ何か欲しいと思ったら
ただそれだけ それやりなさいと
難しい聞かないんです
だから心明確に見えるのは
子供の世界では綺麗に見えるんですね
子供は何か欲しいと言ったら
もう何の理屈も聞かないでしょうね
それは欲しい それだけ
同じです 大人も 自分欲しいものはそれだけ欲しいと思って
行動する それに欲しいものばっかり追っかけていって幸福になるかというと
ほとんどないんです だから
あまりにも美味しさに心の目が見えないんだから
どんな苦しみ どんな危険に自分が遭っているかとは
それは気がつかないんです
億万長者になりたいと思ったら
心に何になりたいんですか？と聞いたらわからないんです
何か言うんです お金さえあれば何でもできる
全部できるんだよとか
そういうのは全部屁理屈で
ただなんとか喋るだけで
そこでじゃあ億万長者になりたい
とにかくなってやると
と決めちゃって もう何やるか
それからはもうわからないんです
何でもする 最低の場合は人殺しでもする
人殺しでもして この生命が幸福になるかというと
全然ならないんですね
ですから 心の特色っていうのは
そういうふうに 随分わがままで
好きという 美味しいということ
それだけ追っていく だから
わかりやすい言葉で大馬鹿もんだというふうにしか言いようもないんです
全く子供と同じなんですね
赤ちゃんでも 例えばもう炎が見たら
見たところすごい綺麗なんですね
行ってそれに手を出して触ろうとする
子供に限って火と包丁も刃物とか好きでしょうに
子供から見れば 刃物っていうのはピカピカ光ってあって
あれ触ってねじって舐めてみたいんですね
子供っていうのは何でも口で認識するんだから
だから 自分の台所にある包丁ね
子供の気持ちだからといって
なめなめ舐めさせてあげたらどうなるんですかね
じゃああんた そんなに舐めたければ
上層包丁を口に入れて舐めてみてくださいと
で 我々は子供だからといって
もういろいろ工夫して
子供が泣いたっても それを気にしないで
そういうものは手に届かないところにしておく
で 火遊びしちゃうんだからね
そんな子供に簡単に火をつけないようにいろいろ工夫をしておく
それで子供を守る 一体大人になったら我々誰が守ってくれるんですかね
誰も守ってくれないんです
大人はいくらか経験があるんだから
包丁を舐めてみたいという気持ちはないんですけど
全く同じく あれは好き
あれは欲しい それだけ
そこでずっと行くんです
それ得てどうなるんですかと
それは考えない 自分欲しいものを獲得するために
自分が選んだ道が正しいかないか考えません
すぐ考えるのは一番近い道はなんですかと
だから一番近い道は一番危ない道なんですね
でお金儲かりたければ一番近い道は強盗をやることだからね
すぐ手にお金入るんだから
だからなんとか人生経験がある人々は
まあそこら辺はまあちょっとそれちょっとやばいんだから
商売でもしましょうと思うかもしれません
それでも我々大人の行動も決して信頼できない
それはこういうふうに理解してください
私の行動は信頼できないんだと
そうでないと この話の意味がないんです
私の行動について全く信頼することは不可能ですと
私が何をやるかということはわかりませんと
で 事実はそういうことなんですね
今すごい大人しくしている人が
ちょっと自分の希望が外れちゃったら
自分好きになったものが自分から離れていっちゃったら
すごいひどいことをするでしょうに
世の中でずいぶん言われてるでしょうに
女性っていうのは優しいんだと
それは自分希望するものを自分の手と自分のものになっている時だけなんです
自分欲しいものは自分から逃げちゃったら
まあ女性ほど怖い動物はいないんです
ですから この我々は何をやるかわからないんです
ものすごい優しい性格の女性であろうとも
自分の希望をなんとかなんとかなっちゃったら何をするかと
もうわかったもんではないんです
だから生まれつき優しいとと言われる人さえそういうことだから
まあ人の心っていうのはそんなもんです
ですから よく我々はこういう話は役に立つためにこういうふうに覚えるんです
私の心は信頼できませんというふうに覚えておくんです
そう覚えておけば 確実にいい方向に行くんです
で あの 例えば心が欲しい欲しいといろんなこと言っても
それはあって 自分に良かったかないかとわからないでしょうに
みんな小さい時からずっといろんな希望があって
その希望だけ考えて頭他のこと何も見えない
全部理屈も合理性も全部捨てて
その目指している目的だけめがけて走っていて
それを得たところで幸福か良かったかとわからないでしょうに
それなのに心は走る それは 1番目理解してほしい心の特色
ずいぶんわがままで勝手で
犬ままで自分の欲しがってるものばっかり追っかけていると
次に2番目に見えることは
この心が自分好きで走っている
そのことをうまくいかないと
それに邪魔されると 心が反対に行動するんですね
ものすごく破壊的になるんです
恐ろしいことをするんです
壊してやるぞと それは簡単にわかりやすいと思います
何か希望して行動する
その目的があって 人生の目的があってずっと生きていると
それ突然その目的がもう達成できなかった
ダメになったと そうすると心はすごいショックを受けちゃって
ものすごい破壊の道に走っちゃうんです
じゃあ得られないんだったら壊してやりますと
だからその道も明確に危ない道なんですね
得られないものは全部壊してやる
普段 我々日常生活の中で
その 2つのそのエネルギーで生きてるんです
人間の生き方は まとめて言うならば
好きなものを得るために生きている
得られない 邪魔するものは全部壊す
その 2種類のエネルギーを持って生きてるんです
どんな道でも純粋でない危険な道なんです
理由は 心っていうのはもともとさっぱり何も理解しない
ものすごい大馬鹿な存在なんです
だから国の 総理大臣として
なんかものすごい精神的な病気な人を選んだことと同じなんです
学校にも行ったことがない
文字も書けない もうさっぱり何の一つもわからない
その上精神的な病気だと
そのような人が国の総理にしちゃったら
国はどうなるんですかね
まあ危なくてしょうがないでしょうね
で 我々の命はそんなもんなんです
我々の支配者がそういう全く頭の悪い心なんです
全く合理的でない心を持ってるんです
それで物事を破壊しようとする
自分の希望通りにいかないと
この皆様方 世の中の人々が精神的に弱いと病気だというのは
この破壊のエネルギーなんです
それもまあいい加減な科学的な考え方なんですね
心が破壊的なエネルギーを持っちゃうと
あ あの人はちょっと精神的にちょっと問題ありと言うんです
欲だけに目がくらんで生きているとか
何も言いません それで私が世の中の心理学っていうのは
問題は全部把握していないと言いたいところなんです
例えばうつ病とか 対人関係で自信がないとか
人に会うと心臓がドキドキするんだとか
そういうものは精神的な病気だと
自信ありすぎな馬鹿者を病気だとは言わないんですね
私は仏教の立場から もう自信ありすぎて何でもやるんだと
あったらあれは病気だと
で またそれは社会の人はそう言わない
すごい活発的で まあやり手だと褒めるんです
そこでいろいろやりたいことはあるんだけど
やっぱり自信がないとやる気が出てこないんだと
家を出て電車に乗った途端
不安でしょうがないんだと
怖くてしょうがないんだという人にだけ
あ あなたは精神科に行って何か治療を受けなさいと
それは世の中にある心理治療方法の世界なんです
だから 破壊的なエネルギーを作っちゃえば
それは精神的な病気で
目が見えなくて 美味しいものばっかり追って
どんなひどいことをしたっても
それは元気だと 言っちゃうんです
ですから 仏教のカウンセリング方法じゃなくて
世の中にある科学的なカウンセリング方法っていうのは
あなたはこの病気の代わりにこの病気になりなさいと
...ということなんです
でも病気はどっちでも同じことだから
例えばみんながんは怖いと
じゃああなたはがんの代わりに高血圧と心臓弱くなっていただいてください
それも命取りでしょうに
別にどうったことないんです
だからこの心を直す方っていうのは
あなた この病気ではなくて
この病気になりなさいということじゃないんです
いい加減な考え方なんですね
病気は病気ですから どんな病気でも結局は最後に命を取ってしまいますからね
そういうことで まあお釈迦様は仏教の立場から見ると
結構いろんな違うことを我々は心を直すとか
違うことを言うんですね
心理学の本で言っていることは言わない可能性はあるんです
いくらかは言いますけど
全部その通りには言わない
じゃあ次に この破壊的な能力って何ですかと少々理解した方がよろしいと思いますね
で 希望通りに物事がいかないとよくわかることは
あの 力の人はやっぱり怒って戦っちゃうんですね
そこは明確ですね もう戦ってるんだと
まあわかりやすく言えば
政治家みたいに もう何かあったら
それでももう負けずに
ある党で自分が何か悪いことしたとバレちゃったら
他の党に行って そこでまたで頑張ると
そこから追い出されたらまた他で
もうとにかくそういうエネルギーを持ってるんですね
もう ですから戦うと それはわかりやすい
それも心理学の世界では病気だとは言わない
あの人はいろんないろんなところで負けたんだけど
でもよくもう戦って もう絶対的にもう行動的で
もう頑張ってるんだとということで
でも仏教から見れば それもまあ結局危ない病気なんですね
そこで戦う心っていうのは
戦うことは希望なんですけど
戦えない時もあります
その時はとにかく破壊したいんですね
他人を破壊したいんだけど
できないんだったらどうします？自分を破壊する
だから相手に あの 何て言いますか
投げようと思って 手榴弾というんですか
手で持って投げる 軍隊の人々持っている手榴弾があるんですね
手榴弾のピンを外しちゃうんです
安全ピンを外して殴る
投げようと思ったところで投げないんです
そうするともう てるんです
10秒で自分が死ぬんです
あるいは安全 あるいは指で押さえたってても
力抜けちゃって まあですから他人を壊そうというエネルギーは心が作るんだけど
壊せない場合は自分を壊れて壊してしまっちゃうんです
で めかなんかうつ病とかね
分裂病とか いろいろ言葉で言ってる病気っていうのは全部怒りのエネルギーなんですね
自分を殺してるんです
心で作った毒で それでなんであんなことをやるんですかね
自分をこう死んで こんなことだったら自分が死んじゃいますよということはわかるはずでしょうに
そんなことをやってはいけないとわかるはずでしょうに
なんでそんなことをするんですかね
心が あるいは心にあるもう一つのすごい我が強いんですね
この前の話に接戦しまってね
私こそ偉い奴らはいませんと思ってるんです
私こそもう絶対的で偉いんだと
そういう自分だけの世界に入ってね
自分だけが偉いと思ってるんです
そういうのは自分の心で聞けば
この世の中で一番偉いのは誰ですか？自分の心に正直に聞くと
私ですよと 答えが出るはずなんです
この世の中で一番好きなのは誰ですかと
正直な人だったらよく考えたらやっぱり私ですよと答えるんです
だからこの嘘の世界からちょっと抜けてほしいんですね
嘘の世界にいると お前さんも嘘を言うんです
私は子供のこと大好きです
あれはものすごい嘘なんです
旦那のこと一番好きですよ
とんでもない嘘なんです
私は命より国のこと好きですよとか
政治家が言うかもしれません
国民のこと一番大事ですよと
あれほど嘘はないんですよ
世の中で だから嘘つきだらけで
だからみんな騙されてるでしょうね
で 我々も自分を騙してるんですね
騙せないで 正直に心を見ると
世の中で一番偉いのは誰ですか？と言えば
やっぱり自分なんです
一番好きなのは誰ですか？と聞いたら
そういうことは実感として心を持ってるんです
心っていうのは馬鹿もんだからそれしかわからないんです
なぜならば 自分言う通りにこの生命が動いてくれるでしょうに
おいしいと言ったものは死んでもしてくれるし
麻薬おいしいと思ったら
もうとにかく何とかしてそれ使うし
使って死んだっても それは気にしない
取り調べられたら それは全然平気
また戻ってきてまた使うんだから
だから私の命令はもうたとえ死んでもやってくれるんだからということでしか心知りませんから
自分心というものはすごい
もうわがままで高慢で
自分こそ偉いと思ってるんです
その自分が偉いという概念とにかく守る
だから  아주 病気になっちゃうんです
例えば社会にいて 何か社会の立場が欲しがっちゃう
そこでやってみたら やっぱり他の人も競争しているんだ
自分には競争したっても
なんか負けそうだと そういうところでなんか分裂病でも作っちゃうんですね
作って自分の自我を守るんです
私が偉いんだと 仕事に行きたくないんだと
仕事に行ったらなんか自分の自信が消えると
わかったら知らないうちになんか家が家から出られなくなっちゃうんです
頭は痛いわ お腹が壊れるわ
熱が出るわ 人混みに入った途端
もうもう気持ち悪くなって倒れるわと
そうするとどうしようもないんです
その人はもう会社に行けないんですね
それであ 病気だから会社に行けないんだと
病気だからまあしょうがないと
それで私こそ偉いという
あの妄想概念 きれいにもう守ったことになっちゃうんです
だからこの精神的な病気っていうのは
全部このなんとかごまかして自我を守るためにやるからくりなんです
それから余計な話なんですけど
人間貶したければね 人間に相手にものすごいダメージ受けて与えて
徹底的に壊したければどうすればいいんですか
人々は人間の社会の中でみんな戦っているでしょうに
相手をみんな足を引っ張りたいでしょうに
人の人を 他人を壊したいでしょうに
みんなそういう気持ちを持ってるでしょうに
でも方法がわからないんですね
すごい簡単です どんな偉い人でも簡単に壊せるんです
どういうことかというと
みんな自我を持ってるんですね
自分という自信 プライド
あれを壊しちゃえば何のこともないんです
あれほど人に嫌われることは世の中でないんです
いわゆる相手を認めてあげないこと
相手の態度を傷つくこと
人の態度を傷つく 傷ついちゃったら
その人はもう永久的に自分のことを嫌うんです
ものすごいもう敵を作る一番簡単な方法なんです
人を馬鹿にする 相手を
みんな勝手にやってるでしょ
大馬鹿もんですからね
心っていうのは 平気で相手の立場を壊すと
口だけでプライドを傷つくことをすると
あれでもうものすごい敵を作ったことになるんです
あとから私はあなたに何も悪いことをしていないのに
なんであなたは私にいろんな腹が立ってるんですか？とかね
夫婦の間でもね 例えばもうもういろいろ喧嘩
いろいろ喧嘩あったりして別れたりして
それからなんで なんで別れたかさっぱりわからないんだと
私は一生懸命もうやったつもりなんですけど
でも相手は私の顔も見たくないんだと
私は住んでる地方にも住みたくないんだ
それぐらい逃げた 逃げたいんだと
なんであれほど嫌われますかというと
どこかでちらっと言ったことで
その人のプライドを傷つけたことがあると思います
その傷跡が大きくなるんです
消えません ですから 我々社会でうまく生きるためには
すごく覚えていなくてはいけないんですね
生命の 他人のプライドだけは
決して傷つかないこと
人を叱っても構いません
いくら叱っても 喧嘩したっても
もうすぐ仲直りできるんです
ちょっと一言でプライドさえ傷いとおけば
もう終わり  それぐらいこの心というものが自分が偉いと思ってるんですね
その概念だけ壊しちゃったら
もう人間では生きていられないんです
で まあ仏教の世界ではね
この自我という高慢をね
捨てること徹底的に教えているんです
なぜならば 全部問題はそこから生まれるんだからと
なぜうつ病になるかというと
自我あるんだからなんですね
私はそういうそういう病気だから
まあしょうがないんだと
私はまあずっと生まれつき
この慢性気管支炎なんとか言うんですか
そういう病気だから まあうまく勉強もできないんだと
仕事もできないんだと
そういうふうに まあ私が悪くはないんだと
病気が悪いんだというふうに言って
自分がいいものになっちゃうんですね
いつでも心はそういう働きなんです
だから この精神的に弱くなる人々っていうのは
簡単にこの逃げ道 自我を守るために簡単に逃げ道選ぶんですね
社会的な立場で言えば
そんな逃げ道は良くないんだと
だからなんとか治そうとしてるんだけど
無理なんですよ この心理学的にね
お医者さんたちがね 一生懸命頑張ってはいるんだけど
結局その方々はね 心の働きは勉強
まあ仏教で見てるような幅広く見てないんだから
それすごい無理なんですね
無理だから薬なんかあげちゃうんですね
薬なんか作ってあげて
それででも抑えてあげようと
ああいうのは全部ごまかしですね
薬を精神安定剤やらね
いろんな薬あるんですけどね
そういうものは飲んで
まあ落ち着いたんだとかね
でもそういうのは治療にはならないんですね
結局最終的にはね ですから
まあ例えばね 自分に自信がなかったと
自信がなくて あの まあうつ病になったと
だから本人がそれで命を守ってるんです
うつ病になって 私が本当は偉いんですが
このうつ病だからちょっと社会に出られないんだと
動けないんだと 私のせいじゃないんだと
それでなんとなく自分の態度
そういうことで回ってるんですね
子供は学校に行きたくない場合はね
まあ朝ごはんが良くなかったから
そういう理由でも言うんです
あるいはなんとかして
ご飯食べないで これ食べられないんだとかね
ああだこうだとか あれ随分もう時間かけたらそれで遅くなっちゃう
で 学校に遅くなったんだよね
だって食べるときすごく時間かかったんだと
それでなんとか言うんですね
そういうことと同じことでね
もう逃げちゃう 正直に言うと
私は学校に行きたくない
だから行かないというふうに言わないんです
何か他の病気で逃げちゃう
だからそこら辺はなんとかして直した方がいいと思いますけど
全く大胆な 今まで我々が考えてないやり方でしか
心のこのプロセスというものは直さなくちゃいけないんですね
で 簡単にまあ まあ最終的な答えは自我を捨てることなんですね
こんなどうでもいい もうくだらない心だから
もう弱くて脆くて 大したことないんだと
誰でも同じだとという
自分という自我を完全にもう置いておけば
自分が何者でもないんだと
そうすると何のことなく生きていられるんです
失敗したっても 全然怒りが出てこない
落ち込まない まあ自分は大したことないんだからということで
全然平気でいられるんです
成功したっても 我ながらよくやるんじゃないかと
全然威張らないんですね
まあうまくいっただけだと
その人がそういう気持ちで生きていられると
絶対病気にならないんです
たまたまうまくいっただけだと
たまたま会社が儲かっただけだと
まあ大したことないんだと
その代わり人間何考えるかというと
私に任せてください 私はこの会社をここまで持ってきたんだと
そういう能力があるんだと
そんな気持ちで自殺しちゃうんです
なぜならば いつでも経済状態は同じじゃないんだから
ですから この自我があっちゃうとすべての問題が生まれてくる
自我が消えると もうほとんどの問題がなくなっちゃうんですね
だからこのまあ 失敗 失敗
失敗したくないと思うのはものすごいバカバカらしい考え方なんです
それ同時にとにかく成功したいんだということも全くバカバカしいんです
そこら辺 仏教と世俗的な心理学の違うところなんですね
成功しましょうと思うことは正しくて
というふうに言ってるんだから
仏教かどっちでも同じだと
失敗したっても別に構わないんだったら
まあたまたま成功したって別に構わないんだと
そういう目で見なくちゃいけないんです
失敗しても構いません
成功したって まあそれでも構いません
その知恵さえあれば 心は全く病気にならない
普通我々はそうじゃないんです
たとえ料理を作ったっても
あ これはすごい美味しいと思ったらすぐ舞い上がっちゃうでしょうに
気をつけてください 精神的な病気になるんです
なぜならば 自分の成功に喜びを感じているでしょうに
だからその同じように
まあこれは食べられないんだと言われたらどうするんですかね
ものすごい怒るでしょ
その時は だから本当に本人も食べられない時あるんです
なのに 相手からそれちょっと食べられないと言ったら怒るんです
だからそこはまあ精神的な病気ですから
そういう人はもうどこかでちょっと道がね
線路が外れちゃったらもうどうしようもないんです
だから正しい見方っていうのは
まあ失敗したっても構いませんし
まあ成功したって まあそれも構いませんと
どっちでも構いませんと
だから成功しても構いませんという考え方はすごく大事な考え方
それまあ気をつけて覚えておけば
もう健康な心を維持することはできるんです
うん まあそれからまあ少々いろいろ治る
直すね 心を直す方法 いろいろ検討してみましょう
で それ僕は新しいことじゃなくて
ずっと言ってることで何かないかと
新しいもたくさんありますけどね
で 皆様に私は慈悲の瞑想を紹介しているんですね
テーラワーダ仏教を教えようと思って
僕は一番最初に合理性と慈悲の瞑想という 2つで始めたんだから
で それでいろんな人から批判は受けましたけどね
そんな話はということで
私は日本でないんだから
合理性と 正しさっていうのは私から見ればなかったんです
こんな非合理的でよく生きてるんだと
もう心配でしょうがなかったんです
これ危ないんで なんとかしてあげなくちゃと
ですからもう合理性教え始めたんだけど
かえって私に怒られたんですね
あんた何言うんですかと
我々はもうすごい合理的な
しっかりした もう西洋文明はもう徹底的に受けて
科学的な知識を徹底的に受けて世界一流ではないかと
そんなこのなんとか数字で
この教育という猿回しでいろいろ数字を見たりして
そんなことを合理だと言うんですかね
私は言わない 合理性あるっていうのは
しっかり生きていられることであって
物事をしっかりと判断できることであって
そのためにすごいもう認識能力があるということだからね
今 チャパツ流行ってるなと思ったらみんなチャパツだから
そんな見たら僕はもう全くもう猿にしかないんだと
何の合理性もないんだと
なんとかブランドの品物が
今はこれやと それですぐみんな行っちゃうでしょうね
誰か誰が 例えばマスコミの人が
誰かがイタリアやらフランスやらどうかで
このうろうろもう夜遊びしている時
何か目についたと それで気に入って
それをここで報道するんですね
した次の日から日本はブームなんですね
そんな生き方に誰が合理と言うんですかね
まあ猿は立派ですけどね
そんな簡単に言うことできませんだからね
ですから やっぱり人間目指しているのは
そういうふうに操られて回されて生きることじゃなくて
自分で回すことなんです
まあとにかく私は合理性と慈悲というこのことを教えましたし
慈悲のことをちょっと考えてみましょう
慈悲の瞑想で我々に何かメッセージあるはずなんですね
私は幸せでありますように
親しい人々は幸せでありますように
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
私の嫌いな人々も幸せでありますように
私を嫌っている人々も幸せでありますように
と そこ何かメッセージあるんです
私は幸せでありますようにということをわかりやすい
ずいぶんわかりやすい
心が幸せになりたいんだから
で でも親しい人々は幸せでありますようにと念じちゃうと
エネルギー半分切れちゃうんですね
私は幸せでありますようにというと
すごい気持ちよく唱える
それ自体 具体的なそういう例あるんです
私にはいろんな人がね
話してくれるんだから
私は幸せでありますようにと言うと
なんとなく感じがわかるんだけど
他のことさっぱりわかりませんだからそれだけ念じても構いませんかと
私は幸せでありますように
それだけ念じても構いませんか？という人々もいますからね
だから ものは私の計算通りにいってるんです
で 私は幸せでありますように
すごい気持ちよく この初めで紹介した時はうるさくてしょうがなかったんです
私は幸せでありますようにということを言うと
それぐらいみんな気持ちよく
今は健康 みんな仏教のことも知ってるんだからね
まあちゃんとなさってますけどね
最初はもううるさいうるさい
怒鳴って言うんで すごい大きな声で
もう周りから文句来たんだから
で 親しい人々は幸せでありますようにというと
あのエネルギーは半分切れちゃうんですね
そこで生きとし生けるものは幸せでありますようにと言うと
なんとなく空回り 残り半分も切れちゃう
そこで私は何のことなく続けて
私の嫌いな人々も幸せでありますようにとやらさせるんですね
それで腹が立って怒って
慈悲のところじゃないんです
なんでそんなことしなくちゃいけないんですかと
ね で わかるでしょ？心のプロセスが
自分のことだったら 100%で
親しい人との場合は 50%で
もう他の人のことだったら 0%で
嫌いな人だったら逆で
で 怒りになっていくんですね
それでもこれやりなさい
それはお釈迦様が考えた
このすっごいこの精神治療方法なんです
だから一つの素晴らしい行動としてやってみなさいと
だから じわじわと徐々に徐々に訓練して
私に入れる 100%のエネルギーは親しい人々にも入れるようになる
そうすると 50%ぐらい生きとし生けるものにも入るんです
さらにやっちゃうと 100%ぐらい生きとし生けるもののこと
幸せでありますようにと言うと
同じ気持ちになるんです
それは同じ気持ちだったら
その人にはこの世の中で何の問題もないはずなんです
何の問題もないはずなんです
すべての精神的な問題は
その時で解決しているはずなんです
生きとし生けるものは幸せでありますようにという時
出すエネルギー 私は幸せでありますようにと出すエネルギーと全く同じになったところで
心の悩み苦しみっていうのは全部消えてるはずなんです
それで精神的な問題は終わるんです
でもそこで仏教は終わりません
そこで嫌いな人々のことも念じちゃうと
ベースに怒りが来なくなっちゃう
生きとし生けるものの場合は
100%になっちゃったら
嫌いな人のことも言っちゃうとあんまりもう感じないというか
その時あのマイナスエネルギーは空回りになる
ただ空回りで嫌いな人々も幸せでありますように
それでさらに続けると
そこら辺の空回り消えちゃうんです
なんか嫌いな人のことをものすごく愛情を感じちゃうんですね
あの人のことを嫌ってはいけませんと
かわいそうじゃないかと
私のことを嫌ってるのは
それはかわいそうだと
その人苦しんでるんだと
なんか私がいろいろ悪いんじゃないかと
これいけないんだと 口は聞いてくれませんだから
心からでも念じてあげなくちゃいけないと
そういうふうに この嫌いな人のことは
やっぱりポジティブ方向へが 50%ぐらいエネルギーは生まれてくるんです
そういう人々は精神的に健康的ところじゃないんです
そういう人々は人間に光を与えているリーダーシップを取るんです
そういう人々はただの人間で生きているんじゃなくて
もう社会の中で堂々たる本当の王様のように生きてられることできるんです
もう敵敵がいないんだから
そこで瞑想のこの順番なんですけど
私を嫌っている人 私が嫌いな人とかいう風に言うと
本当に意味がわかって感じて
本当の正直な心でそれを念じられる
正直な気持ちで念じられると
さらに瞑想を続けると
私は幸せがありますようにと念じることは馬鹿馬鹿らしくなっちゃうんです
なんだこうつまらない
それ空回りになるんです
空回りになっちゃって
親しい人々は幸せでありますように
ところで元気になって瞑想を始めちゃうんです
そうすると順番でこのパーセントが上になって
嫌いな人の場合も 50%以上エネルギーは入っちゃうんです
それで我々出家が瞑想しちゃうと
さらに瞑想しなくちゃいけないんです
どういう風にするかというと
親しい人々は幸せでありますように
とこも空回りになっちゃうんです
なって いきなり生きとし生けるものは幸せでありますように
それで始まるんです それでやっと慈悲の瞑想は完成するんです
結構長い修行ですけど
長い修行ですけど  1 分やっても
その人は素晴らしく心を育てるんです
たった 1 分でも でもたった 1 分でも正直にやってほしい
そこでこのこの病気治します
この病気症状を治しますというそんな話じゃなくて
仏教でいきなり第3レベルで
ものすごい高度なレベルで人に清らかな心の道
強い心の道 これですよと言うんです
それは患者さんにもできるし
がんになったってもその瞑想できるし
だから万人に効く薬なんです
キリスト教であろうともできるし
イスラム教徒であろうとも何のことなくできるし
最初はピンとこない ピンとこなくてもやらなくちゃいけないことなんです
あると この心のエネルギーというものは
じわじわと成長する だから
最初に私に言った人々がね
嫌いな人々のことを思うと
ものすごく気持ち悪くなって
もう瞑想できなくなるんだと
やっぱり まあ私の計算通りなんですけど
もう一ついい反面があるんですね
正直にやってみたということなんですね
正直にやってみたところで
自分の正直な気持ちはこういう気持ちだと
それで そういう方々は自分を観察してほしい
これでいいんですかと
嫌いな人は嫌いますと
私の嫌いな人々は死んでしまえと
親しい人々だけ幸福になれと
そういう概念でいいんですかね
と自分に聞けば あ いけませんとわかるでしょうに
じゃあ私は成長しなくちゃいけないと
という答えがそこに合理的に見ると出てくるんです
でも人間が合理的じゃないんだから
やっぱり私はそれを抜けますと
嫌いな人々は幸せでありますように
僕は抜けますというふうなわがままですね
あれは抜ける権利あるわけ
それお釈迦様がおっしゃってるんだから
あなた誰ですかと聞きたいんです
悟ったお釈迦様がおっしゃっているんだから
もうもうちょっと一歩先歩いたら何がなるかわからないね
馬鹿な人間が 私はあれ抜けますと
権利ないんです ですから
お釈迦様がおっしゃったんだから
もうやるしかないんです
お釈迦様はわかってから言ってるんだから
自分でご自分で実行して仰ってるんだから
で 仏教の理想的な慈悲の瞑想というのは
あまり私は幸せでありますようにと言わないことなんです
そればっかりやってみてください
また混乱するんです 欲ばっかし出てきて
ですから その瞑想は 生きとし生けるものは幸せでありますように
というところから始まれるまで
ずっとやってみれば もう人間の心を直すどころじゃなくて
我々はものすごい偉大なる
ものすごい強力な精神的なパワーを持っている人間になるんです
だからお釈迦様は慈悲の心ある人はブラフマン梵天
これはヒンドゥー教の考え方で見れば神様なんです
宇宙全ては創造した その人になるんだと
だからそういう宗教的なシンボルまで使ってお釈迦様がおっしゃったのは
それぐらい偉大なる精神的なパワーが自分に身につきますよと
その教えを見てください
すごい科学的でしょうに
合理的でしょうに 万人に合うでしょうに
それから これは現代人に合わないとか
未来人に合わないとか
21世紀のその教えはダメですか？と言える人がいるんですかね
いるんだったら連れてきてください
これは 21 世紀の時代にありません
そんな教えとは  それじゃあ生きとし生けるものって念じてますね
皆さんおっしゃるから私もこう言うんですけど
そうするとあのいやらしいゴキブリとかヘビとか
そういうものもみんな入るわけですね
そうそう すべて入る 生命であるならば
だから私たちの生命に対する態度が変わるんですね
今はおっしゃる通りにいやらしいヘビだと
でもすごい態度が低いんですね
大きな人間はいやらしいとも思わないんですね
例えば 私たちはお互いに社会の中で
会社の中でお互いに喧嘩したり
嫉妬したりする 例えば天皇陛下はそういうことを嫉妬したりするんですかと
しないでしょうね もうすごい大きい方だから
どんなヘドメタってもそれなりにもう挨拶をして話すと
話す機会があったならば
そういうふうに比べると
偉大なる人が人が偉くなっちゃうとつまらないものはまあいいんじゃないかと
例えば兄弟 小さな子供はお互いに
お兄ちゃん 私の鉛筆取ったよとものすごくぶん殴って喧嘩したりするでしょうに
それで母親もいい加減にしなさいよと
母親大きいんですね ですから
あんまり区別考える人は小さい
まあ全部大きな傘で巨大な傘で全部覆っている人は大きいんです
そこまでとにかく精神を育てると
で 仏教の難しいところはそういうところなんです
いつでもこのそのままでなんとかごまかそうということは全くない
このプラスteringという英語の言葉で言えばね
例えば何か割れたところにちょっとバンドを貼ってプラスteringをやって OK やと
それは OK じゃないんですね
その代わりにとことん育てて育てて
進化して 進化して 成長して巨大化になることを考えているんです
ですから おっしゃる通りに
もう一切の生命に対してすごい優しい心で見られると
それこそ神の心なんです
我々宗教で聞いている神っていうのはすごい品格
品がないんです 敵を倒すんだから
信じてない人は地獄に落としちゃうんだから
人間と何も変わりがない神なんですね
聖書であるんで 私は嫉妬の神だよという言葉までジェラスゴッド
とそれ我々スリランカですいぶんキリスト教の人とからかっちゃうんですね
あんた方の神 ジェラスゴッドではないかと
やっぱりそれはまあそのまあ宗教は人間作るもんだから
心育ててない人間作ったんだから
やっぱり敵 は倒すべきだよとすごい単純に考えちゃうんですね
あの人たちは言ってることをやってくれない
社会性は持ってない だから排除するべきですよという
ものすごい単純な考え
そこに慈悲がない だからすぐ仏教の人にそう言うと欠点バレちゃうんですね
あ この宗教おっしゃってる人は神の声を聞いてるんじゃなくて
ただの人間で 自分の感覚を喋ってるんだと
心育てていうとわかるんですね
例えばイエス様が人ほっぺた殴られたら
向こう側もあげなさいというと
それにあまり文句言えないんですね
でも表はなんかバカバカらしく見えるんです
ユダヤ教ではぶん殴ったらぶん殴れと
目には目だと 歯には歯だと
正しいんだと なんか合理っぽく見えるんですね
すごい合理じゃないんです
あれは あれは心を育ててない普通の人間の考え方で
イエス様はその旧約の快速をやめて
私は新しいことを教えますと
モーセの十戒をもう置いといて
新しいことを教える 目には目ではなくて
ほっぺた殴ったら次のほっぺたもあげなさい
上着を取ろうとするんだったら
下着もあげよう 全く正反対のことを言ってますね
ですから なんか非合理的に感じちゃうんですね
人は私を騙して私の上着を取ろうとすると
じゃあ私のこれもズボンもあげますよと
なんかバカバカバカバカらしいじゃないんだ
あれは本当のすごい心で言ってる言葉なんです
そこにあるのは その人はなんと
例えば上着がない 上着がないんだか
上着がある人のものをほしがっちゃう
だからいろいろからくりをやっている
ごまかしをやっている
そこであげませんよときつくする人は同じ同格の人間で偉い人が
まあやっぱりその人たちはかわいそうでしょう
もう上着はないし 寒いし
ですから なんか私の上着を取ろうといろんな工夫をやってるんだと
なんかかわいく見えるんですね
愛情で じゃあどうぞこれ取ってくださいと
その気持ちで言うんですね
その心育てなさいというメッセージですから
そちらには明確に見えるんですね
成長した心と成長した心で喋った言葉だと
そういう言葉は人類の中で残る
ですから この慈悲の慈悲を持って
我々はとにかくゴキブリのところから微生物まで
ウイルス細菌まで優しい心で見られるように育てなくちゃいけないんです
それは人間に対して答えなんです
ウイルスにやられるんだからいたら
そこはもう同格でウイルスと同じなんで全然成長してないんです
それは敵を倒すということと同じですからね
ですから この仏教でいう心育てる方法っていうのは
ちょっと薬が頭が痛い
だからバファリン飲みなさいという風な
このごまかしじゃないんです
頭が痛い人はバファリン飲んだら頭が治ったわけじゃなくて
騙してるだけでしょうに
自分を騙してるだけ 本当は答えてないんですね
がんになったらそこの部分は切って捨てると
その人治ったことじゃないんです
あれはもう騙しちゃうんですね
それは育ててない世界で
精神的に心を育てない世界で
そういうふうな学問も科学も発展しますけど
お釈迦様は言うの やっぱりそれではなくて
やっぱり根本からもう治して育てる育てると
ということで 病気になってどうしようもない時
仏教を実践しようじゃなくて
かなり先から準備しておいた方がいいんで
この一晩一夜漬けというんですか
子供たち勉強する時はね
まあ試験は明日ですから
今日夜勉強するんだと
そんな勉強あるんですか？世の中で
そうじゃなくて ずっとこつこつとゆっくりと勉強すると
一夜漬けじゃなくて ちゃんと事なく試験合格できるんです
一晩で勉強して試験合格できるなら
私も弁護士の資格でも取りたいんだけどね
でもそれはできないんだからね
ですから このどうしようもない時
なんとか助けてちょうだいというのは
本当は望みないんです
ですから まあ仏教の本当の意味理解したければ
仏教の本当の味を味わいたければね
すごい健康な時 何も問題ない時
自分がもう元気満々でピンピンで
もう仕事はできるわ もう何の問題もないわ
頭はすごく行動するわ
そういう時始めなくちゃいけないんです
いくらでも成長する道があるんだから
どーんと病気になったところで
もう死にかけている時は
まあちょっと生うどぶすぐらい
しか言ってあげることはできないんだけどね
で たまにね まあまあ僕らも坊主だからね
まあそういう人々に会ったりするので
やっぱり悲しいんです
会った時はすごく自分もなんとなく嫌になっちゃうんです
なぜかというと 問題見えてるんです
なぜこうなったかと どうするべきかとも知ってるんだけど
その人にとってはそれはもう遅すぎ
too late ということで
いろいろがんのこととか出てきたんだから言いますけど
例えば生まれた時からわがままで好き嫌いが激しくて
偏食で生きていて  48歳で健診でところでがんになった
がんですよと言われたんだと
で 私 何とかなる方法ないんですか？と
48年間悪いことをしてなったがんが
1時間で治りますかね
治すためには 48 かける 2 かかるんです
心を抑えて治すためにはどれぐらいですかね
48年ではなくて その 2倍修行しなくちゃいけないんです
だからまあすごい悲しくなるんですね
もうほんのちょっとしたことで
なんですけどね 例えば食べ物の場合は
怒りで 食べる 高慢で食べる
見栄で食べる そう言ったらわからないと思いますけどね
例えば見栄で食べるということは
まあ私はまあこういう高いものしか食べないんだと
私は上等なこの肉しか食べないんだと
私はこの酒しか飲めませんとか
それブランド決めて見栄なんですね
そこにあるのは それでずっと
だから結婚してても 母親にもう何いる？もう母親もだいたいみんな病気だからね
見栄で育てるんだからね
いろんな食べ物に癖ついてあげちゃう
それで結婚した時 奥さんも大変なんですね
その人何が気に入るかわからないんだから
もしそういうものすごいもう例えばものすごい高いものばっかり食わない人だったら
これすごい大変なんで
経済的にしたって だからそういう見栄で食べる
それから怒りで食べる
それから欲で食べるということはわかりやすい
自分が私はこういうもの好きですよと
いつでもそればっかり食べると
大量に買ったり買ってきて
いろんなもの そういうことで細胞をいじってるんですね
体を攻撃しているんです
だから体に栄養を与えたんじゃなくて
心のわがままを してあげただけなんですね
ですから 心はどうせ大馬鹿もんだから
この体はもうどうしようもなくて
例えば車に悪い燃料を入れたことになるんです
車の種類によって燃料やらルブリケーションオイルというなんか油入れちゃいますね
滑走とかね そういうのは決まってるんですね
どんな番号 どんなものか
純粋なガソリンを入れなくちゃいけない車に灯油を入れたったらどうなるんですかね
壊れるでしょうね 例えばガソリンで動く車があるんだと
ガソリンじゃなくて灯油で動く車があるんだ
そこで私 今お金あるんだから
ガソリン入れますと 灯油の代わりに入れてみてください
灯油で動く車だったら
それにガソリン入れちゃったら
その車動かないんで壊れるんですね
だから この食べ物やら習慣やらね
この見えて高慢で欲で怒りでやってるんだから
体はもうすごい早くきちんと病気になるんです
それで病気になった部分だけ捨てると
答えにならないんですね
ですから やっぱり落ち着いて体が要求する食べ物を与えてあげると
たとえ安い安くたっても
体に必要なものをあげればいい
例えばイワシなんか安いんだから食べないとかね
ずっとあったんで それでテレビでイワシは食べたら全ての病気治りますよと言ったんだから
それでイワシがキュンと高くなったんだけど
で そういう風に何とか高満足ってもらわなきゃ食べないんです
ホウレンソウでがんが治りますよと言ったら
もうそれで取って食べるし
そうでないとそんな安いもん食わませんと置いておいたりする
そこでわかるでしょ？自分の見栄というもの
高慢というもの そんなものは体に関係ないでしょうに
これ食物だから だからこのがんになる方々はもう精神的な病気だから
もともとに がんになってしまっちゃうんです
で そこはそういうことで
またどうしようもなくがんになる場合もありますよ
自然破壊して食べ物を
人間の欲ばっかし食べ物を作ってるんだから
人の命考えてないでしょうに
美味しく作ろう 形を美しく作ろう
大量に作ろう お金かからないで
そこで高いお金で売ろうと
そんな恐ろしいことをやって
そういうのを食べると
我々も食べ物ないんだから
そういうものを食べなくちゃいけないし
それでどうしようもなくがんになる場合もありますけどね
自分のわがままでがんになったりする場合もありますよ
それどっちかとね まあまあ
どっちかにしたっても
やっぱり治るのは難しいというかね
まあ時間かかるということで
じゃあそういう話をちょっと置いておいて
ちょっと話もうかなり逸れてしまっちゃって申し訳ないんだけど
この慈悲のことで このどんどん心はそういうふうに共理性になると
確実に心が治るし そこで一つメッセージは
私というこの独立した高慢的な個体的な気持ち
それ消えちゃうんですね
それ消えて ものすごい大きな人間になるんです
小さなガラス あるいはこの小さなもう茶碗に入っている水ではなくて
自分が大自然の水になってしまっちゃうんです
で それが安心ですからね
そのメッセージ そういう方法で心治すんですけどね
心を治す  バリバリ道はそれしかないんです
また まあいろいろ簡単単純なね
つまらない つまらないではなくて
またいろいろもありますけど
で 前で僕は論理的なことを言ってね
無常に逆らうとかね 人々は無常は認めないんだと
あんまりも屁理屈だと
すべては変化するんだと
それは科学的な事実だよと認めなさいと
だから変化してはいけませんと思っちゃうんだから
精神的な病気だとね 子供が大きくなって家出ちゃったら母親が病気になると
冗談じゃないですよ それは子供が大きくなるのは
これは自然なことだから
大きくなって独立して家を出るのは自然なことだから
それで認めたくないんだというならば
もう怒るしか方法ないんですね
僕らにしたっても それから自分が元気がなくなったと
やる気が消えちゃったと
腰がものすごく痛くなってくるんだと
歩けなくなったとか 随分わがままなんですね
ですから 無常を認めないんですね
人間っていうのは それほど頭が悪いんだったら
もうもうもう失格なんですね
生命として 会社の収入がもう減ったと
それで自分が病気になってしまったと
冗談じゃないでしょうに
これは無常だから だから
人間のこの頭のあまりの悪さというか
このもう知恵の世界のもう失格ですね
初めからそういう人々だけですよ
ほとんどね 問題作ったりするのは
で ある 最近の政治家ですか
まあ自殺した みんなびっくりしたんだと
私だけびっくりしてなかったんだけどね
どう見ると臭いんですね
初めから で その人がすごい信頼していたんだと
やる手やり手で 若い人で
私はずっとその人をずっとではなくて
結構私の頭に入ってた一つの人物なんですね
この人は怒りではないかと
小さい時から 怒りで偉くなってやると
他のものを全部抑えて抑えて抑えて
なんとかことで自分の立場を作ろうと
だからそれには何でもすると
だから頭がいいんだから東大に入るんじゃなくて
そういうことに必要だから
東大は認められているんだから
東大に入る 情報を頭に詰め込めれば
一番簡単に東大に入れるんです
性格は見ないんだからね
東大では ですから 頭の頭のいい人にちょっと入りにくいところなんですね
なぜならば 自分の意見を持ってるでしょ
もし試験なんか自分の意見やら自分が言いたいこととか何か書いちゃったら
そこでもう点数もらえませんし
全部決まってる情報をそのまま入れちゃったらね
答案として合格するんですね
それはしょうがないんですけど
まあ競争激しいんだからそうなっちゃうし
ですから 本当に自分の意見を持っていて
自分のビジョンを持ってる人には入りにくい
まあとにかくそこは置いておいて
まあそういうところを認めているんだから
そこに入ると 弁護士っていうのは
そういう中で認めているんだから
弁護士になってみると
自分がなりたくてなったわけじゃないんですね
社会そう認められているんだから
一番偉いというのは もうどうせ政治の世界だから
力 だからもう政治家になる
で 政治家になったところで
政治家は何やるかというと
やっぱり我々のことをあんまりにも慈悲深いんだから
政治家になったわけじゃないんだから
向こうは商売だからね
で そこで政治家の間で力強いのは金持ちなんです
金の力で相手を抑えなくちゃいけないんだ
他のライバルを ですから
会社であろうが 銀行であろうが
証券会社であろうか ヤクザであろうか
鬼であろうがかまわず収入を得なくちゃいけないんです
政治世界で自分の立場を作るために
ですから その怒りでそういうふうに言っている人の最終結果は自殺なんです
それでそれできなくなったあと
それは純粋な怒りが出てくるんです
じゃあ死んでやると どうぞと
私は私は言いたい ない
どうぞ だからそれで我々普通の国民がすごい悲しくなるだろうと
えらい勘違いしているんですね
誰も悲しくないんです
で 仏教から言えばもうかわいそうでね
大失敗 人生なせなら来世の失敗だからね
ものすごく強烈な怒りで死ぬ人は
怒りの次元に落ちちゃうんですね
怒りしか生きていられないところに生まれ変わっちゃうんです
そういうところで すごいこの鬼たちの世界とこのストーリーで言ってるのはそういう世界なんですね
別に鬼たちの世界があるかどうか
僕は見たことがないんだからわかりませんだけど
やっぱりこの生命の次元を知っていた方々は人間にわからないんだから
やっぱり綺麗なストーリー作っちゃうんですね
鬼たちの世界とか 特に戦って喧嘩して
あれは生きるための食べ物と同じなんです
で 戦いて戦った相手を壊して怪我させると
それで自分の栄養になっちゃうし
で 自分も同じく人に他の生命に殴られて
ものすごく嫌になって壊れて粉々になったら
自分はそれで栄養だから死なない
そういうふうにそういう次元あるんです
だから我々とこの DNA を持ってる生命ではない
でもとにかく まあどう見ても怒りで死ぬ人は天国に行くっていう話はちょっと言いにくいことなんですね
詳しい話私もわかりませんだけど
もうただ知ってる ちらちらと知ってる情報から随分勝手な判断しちゃうと
そう考えてしまっちゃう
そこで日本でよくあることは簡単に自殺するんですね
ですから そういう人々にもともと生きる失格ことは失格なんですね
ただ 世の中うまくいくんだから
おかげでうまくいっただけで
世の中ちょっと変化すると
この連中は自殺しちゃうんですね
だから弱さもものすごいいいところなんです
社長が三人自殺したんだと
ものすごいもう経営状態悪くなったと
社長になる権利まるっきりなかったんですね
失格 資格はなかったんです
何か経営してやるという人は
社会環境までいろいろコントロールして儲かるようにする人でしょうに
そうじゃなくて 世の中の経済状態
ものすごくうまく動いていると
どんな馬鹿者にも金儲かることできるんです
そこで回転がちょっと壊れたらこれ壊れるんだったら
別にどうってことないんです
それより私はもう人間のことを気になりますから
なんでそんなに弱いんですかと
弱いんだからバカなことをするし
それでもう大量に儲かった
いろんなところにお金出したりするし
もう取りたい放題 いろんな銀行からあっちこっちからお金取っても
うまくいくかいかないかさっぱり考えない
だから気を付けるとか計算するとかもう全くない
ただもうなんとかやればいいんだと
あれ 心のバカバカらしさなんですね
こういうことをやれば
もしかすると儲かるだろうと
もしかすると億円儲かると
もしかするとで商売できるわけじゃないでしょうに
だから科学性 合理性ってないということは明確でしょうに
たまたま日本みたいな
この素晴らしい環境 いいところに生まれたんだから
もうちょっとうまくいっただけのことで
全然褒めるべきじゃないと思いますね
厳しい環境でもう大きくなったならば
それは素晴らしいんです
例えばもう経済状態は全部悪いのに
ある会社がある人々がその中で何かいろいろ工夫して
もう倒産しないで儲かるようになっているというならば
それはもう知恵というか知識というか
賢いところなんですね
そういうことで やっぱりこのもともとも弱いし
ただ流れに入って自分をちょっと流してもらって
流れが止まったらまあどうしようもなくという人になっちゃうし
それだけで自分の生き方が弱いんだから
そのもうちょっと考えてみましょう
その人々は自殺するまでの前の自分の精神状態
借金はあるわ もう物は売れないわ
全然儲かってないわ それで会社作ったんだから
儲からなくたってお金かかっちゃうんですね
それすごい危ないんですね
だから儲かっていると
その分で費用必要な経費払えますけど
全然儲からなくたっても経費はかかりますし
それで銀行から断られるわ
それも小さな額じゃないんだから
その間のどれほど地獄の苦しみを味わうでしょうかね
だからもうやりきれなくて
もう自殺しちゃうしね
だからかわいそうです
ですから やっぱり我々は最初から
子供の時からもしっかり生きることを覚えた方がいいんです
しっかりと生きること
そうでないと で 次に まあもう時間なくなりましたけど
まあ次の もう一つ この慈悲の瞑想から言いたいポイントなんですけど
この私たちはヴィパッサナー瞑想ということも紹介しているし
慈悲の瞑想も紹介しているし
で ヴィパッサナー瞑想というのは智慧の瞑想で
この徹底的に智慧を持って客観的にすべてを見られるようになると
で それで悟るんだから
もう問題は全くないんですね
で 物事を見られる見られる人にはまあ問題はないんです
例えば会社に行って昇格したんだけど
その物事を見られるんだったら
昇格してもどのように仕事をすればいいかと見えるはずなんです
知恵がない人は ああ どうしようか
こんな立場になったんだからといって
すぐ自信なくなっちゃって仕事ができなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから ヴィパッサナーで知恵を育てると
みるみるうちに心が治るんです
みるみるうちに で 治って
この我々の心の この怒りと欲の激しい波ではなくて
なんか落ち着いている静かな波を作っちゃうんです
心に  失敗しても構いません
成功しても まあそれも別に構いませんと
全然驚きもないし 落ち込みもないし
ある一定のクールな心の波
それを作っていただければ
もうすごい最高なんですね
で あの 現代の人間には
現代でも昔でもね やっぱりこのまず合理的な知識もないし
知恵もない なんかやっても科学は発展するんだけど
どこかで もう全く合理使わない
ですから ヴィパッサナーの心は必要
それからこのもう一つ危ないこと
社会にあるんですね あの例えば
例えば 子供を育てるのは教育の仕事なんですね
子供の時から育てていないと
ある一定に育てることできませんだからね
それで現代 教育がないんですね
社会は発展すればするほど
教育ということは消えちゃうんですね
ある意味で問題がなる問題になると私は思いますね
私の言葉はなんか分かりにくいかも
なんで教育がないんですかと
ないんです とにかく 教育っていうのは
もう人を育てること しっかりした人間を作ることなんです
ですから これ 母親にも仕事でもあるし
父親の仕事でもあるし
おじいちゃんばあちゃんの仕事でもあるし
村人の仕事でもあるし
みんなの仕事なんですね
なぜならば 母の子供だから母の仕事がありますよ
家の子供だから家のみんなの仕事なんですね
教育っていうのは 村の一員だから村の仕事もなるんですね
だって村人の一員で まあどうしようもない人間だと思ったら村が困るでしょうに
それで国の仕事にもなるんですね
国民の一人なんですけど
どうしようもないんだと
ですから 正しい教育っていうのは
死ぬまでしっかりと平和で
みんなと仲良く美しく生きていられる能力をつけてあげることなんですね
現代 この発展している我々
この 21 世紀になっている
この教育っていうのは
そういうことを教えることじゃないんです
ただ 教育という言葉を使っているだけで
何をやっているか私もわかりませんね
いろんなものを覚えさせる
この数学にしてもマラソンやっちゃう
それでとにかくなんとかなんとか合格しましたと
そういうこの紙 1枚だけよく大事にする
いろいろ無機質ないろんなことをやって
この数字がどれぐらい出るかとかね
だからまるっきりこの裏にある人間を忘れているんですね
教える側も教えられる側も
母親は子供のあれ 何といいますかね
この学校から持ってくるいろいろ試験のね
あれで何点ある数字で見るんですね
100点満点だったら喜びと 45点だったらもう怒鳴ると
人が消えてるんです 我々の世界から
現代人はとにかく私の親切な言葉で言えば
現代人が人間を殺してるんです
もう人間はいません 数字しか存在しない
だからまるっきり人を育てていない
ですから 教育は 0 これ数学はできるんだとかね
測りでものを測れるんだとか
何ですかね あれは 地球の大きさは知ってるんだとか
日本の遠い昔からどんなどんな天皇が現れたとか
全部リスト知ってるんだとかね
何月何年何が起きたかとかね
戦国時代何ですかとか
奈良時代何が起きたとかね
あれ なんで何のためにやるんですかね
あんなことは 何の役にも立ちませんでしょう
だから子供たちも知ってます
これは単なるこのなんとか合格しましたという薄っぺらの紙のためにやることであって
生きるためには何一つも教えてくれないんですね
だからそのまま大学に行って
まあ大学からは別にそういう教育はいいかもしれませんだけども
大学の仕事もやっぱりものすごい大事なんです
そこで大人ですから そこを出ると社会人だから
教育はない 単なるなんかもう恐ろしいことをやっているんですね
それで我々 この文明社会を作って
一つ忘れたんですね 我々は生き物であると
足し算 割り算は知ってるんだけど
愛情はないんですね そういうことで
やっぱりみんな生きてるんだと
生きてることは前提だと
どう生きるかという それはそれは一番大事だと
ですから それは本当の私たちっている教育
教育 教育なんです この前も同じことを言いましたけど
繰り返し今日の話は全部繰り返しになっちゃいましたけどね
あの ただ仕事の訓練が教育じゃないんです
今 幼稚園からやっているのは仕事の訓練でしょうに
それも子供たち知ってるんですから
ありとあらゆる仕事の訓練を受けたってば
人しか仕事をしないんだから
大きくなったら このもの全部無駄なんですね
でまあいっぱい勉強することはいいんだけど
僕私もそれに全く反対しませんだけど
で 頭を磨けば磨くほどよろしいしね
物事を知れば知るほどよろしいんだけど
同時に性格を直してほしいんです
立派な人間になってほしい
立派な青年になってほしい
だから小学校でこういうことを勉強したというよりは
こういうふうにみんなと遊んで
何々さんと何々さんとこういうこういうことをやって
ああだこうだ そこら辺に命があるんですね
だからそこは忘れちゃったんですね
この競争的な この知識を積み込む
職業訓練場ですからね
今の教育っていうのは
役に立たない職業訓練所
なぜ役に立たないかというと
会社に入ったらまた初めから教えないと何も仕事ができないんですから
全部お金かかってまた教えなくちゃいけない
だからそこら辺もうちょっとこの人間だよと生命だよとということをわかると
なんとかなるだろうと
なんでそういうことを言いますかというと
ちょっとしたストーリーがあるんです
仏教の物語 どういう物語かというと
この昔々 お釈迦様の先生の話です
で お釈迦様はブッダになる前に菩薩として覚醒で
ある 国の名前とか全部インドの国の名前しか使ってないんだけど
そうでないとインド人はわかりませんだからね
ある国で生まれたんだと
生まれた家族は音楽家の家族
そこでまあ音楽大学ありましてね
まあインドで昔あったんです
まあ大学的な教育 インドはものすごく昔からあったんだから
それを出て 1流の音楽家になりましたと
それであまりにも 1流の音楽家だから
王様のところでまあ仕事をもらって
毎日王様のお世話をしているんだと
そこで その国で 他の国々でも
彼ほどの立派な音楽家はいなかったんだと
そこで その村の その町国の人々が
商人のグループが商売をしようと
品物をいっぱい車に乗せて
もう他の国に行ったんだと
車 500台ぐらい持っていって
車っていうのはこの今の車じゃないんです
昔の そこを行って商売しながら
あの ある日 商売も終わったところで
金も儲かったところで
まあみんなよく食べて
楽しく一つやりましょうという
まあ普通に誰でもやることで
で みんな集めてなんかまあパーティーやってるんですね
そこでまあ寂しいんだから音楽でも聴きましょうと
聞いたら その国の人々に聞くんですよ
なんかすごい名前知られてる音楽家でもいるんですか？って言ったら
うん あんた方お金もあるんだから
この国の一流の音楽家を紹介してあげるんだと
言ったら はい わかりますと
お金いくらでもありますから
連れて来いと言って連れてきたんです
連れてきたら ある人が
若い人が一生懸命演奏しているんですね
それでこの商人たちが別にもう酒飲んだり
ご飯食べたり みんなでいろんなことを喋ったりしてるんです
全然音楽聴いて聞かないんですね
それでこの人は この連中はただお金あるだけで
私を雇ったんだけど まるっきり音楽のことを知らない連中だと思ったんです
思って怒ったんですね
やっぱりもうすごいプロだから
自分の演奏を聴いてくれないと
やっぱり態度気づくんですね
怒って あなた方はね 音楽ということはまるっきり知らないんですね
なんで私を呼んだんですか？と
お金あるんだからと呼ぶなと言ったら
あれ 君演奏したっけと
まだまだ あの調整 まだまだ楽器の調整やってると思っていたんだけどと言ったんですね
言われたら その人は何を言うんですかと
一生懸命演奏したんではないかと
ああ その演奏 ああ それ演奏ですかと
ああ 私たちにとってはただの楽器の調整みたいなもんだよと
言ったら あの人のプライドがなくなっちゃったんですね
自分がすごいプロだと思っていたんだけど
なんであなた方そんなこと言うんですかと
あなた方に言う権利がないんだと
音楽 あなた方聞いたことあるんだと
あるかと聞いたら じゃあ私の国に来てみてくださいと
私の国ではこういう名前の先生がいるんだと
彼に弟子入りでもしたらどうですかと言ったら
その人 やっぱり私の私はこの国一流であって
精一杯演奏したっていうの
この連中がただの楽器調整してるだけではないかと言うんだから
もうよっぽどの人ではないかと思って
その場でそのグループと一緒にその国へ行ったんです
行って この先生の家に行ったんです
そしたら先生の母親がいるんです
両親がいるんだけど 年だから目が見えない
だからこの音楽の先生は両親を朝に水を体を洗ってあげて
ご飯作って食べさせて
全部面倒を見て 王様のところに仕事に行く
で 帰ってきたらまたお世話をすると
で この人が帰った時はこの先生はいないんですね
もう仕事に行って そこでもう楽器やるんです
音楽家の家だから そこで自分がこのヴィーナとか持って
まあ一人でいるんだから
じゃあ練習でもしようかと
演奏でもしようかと思って
自分で楽器を弾いたんだそうです
弾いちゃったら 目が見えない
この両親があのシュッという音を出しながら叩いたんだと
この床を なんで叩いたかというと
この子ネズミを追い出したんです
あ ネズミが来て あの あの子の楽器を噛んでるんです
見えないんだから そこでネズミが来て楽器を噛んでるというぐらい
もうその人のことを言われるんだからね
言ったらもうプライドは完全に消えちゃったんですよ
やっぱり目が見えない人もそう言うんだったらね
自分の演奏はそんな程度だと
言って 両親のところにこのしゃがんで頭を下げて
私は遠い国からね 弟子入りに来たんだから
私に教えてくださいと
言ったら あの子はもう出て行ったんだから
まあそろそろ来るんでしょうと
だから一緒に行ってみればと
そしたら先生が午後帰ってきたんですね
帰ってきたら一人がいる
そしたら両親がこの子はなんか勉強したいということで弟子入りしたいんだと
そしたらこの人の体見たいんですね
見て あなたね 帰りなさい
その場で追い出しちゃったんです
あなたにはいかなるわけがあっても教えませんと
どういうことかというと
その人の性格が悪いと
人はできてないんだけど
それだったら職業訓練もさせてあげないということなんです
菩薩なんです お釈迦様の先生なんです
ですから で 追い出して
追い出したらこの人帰るわけにいきませんし
毎日両親の面倒を見て
面倒を見て 機嫌取って
機嫌取って まあで 両親がもうあんたそんな硬いこと言わないで
あの子になんか教えたらどうですかと
教えたらと 言ったら じゃあ職業だけ教えるんだと
立ちさわりたくない 行って教えたんです
音楽を この人もやっぱりそれなりに才能があったし
まあみるみるうちにものすごく上手になったんですね
そしたらもうすぐ終わったら
まあ終わりましたと 終わったところでまた先生だから
やっぱり気持ちが出てくるんですね
やっぱりもう合格はしました
それからこの人の人生の面倒を見なくちゃいけない
これからちゃんと職業を探してあげて
仕事を捜してあげなくちゃいけないんだと
先生として それで行ったんですね
王様のところに それで言って
王様 今日は紹介したい人がいるんだと
誰でと 私は弟子が一人できたもんで
あの王様に紹介してあげたいんだと
ああ そうですか 先生の弟子ですかね
じゃあ毎日宮に行ってください
まあ給料払いますからと
あなたの給料の半分あげますと
で 王様が先生のことをずいぶん信頼してるんです
なんてことなく まあいいですよ
もう仕事を毎日来てくださいと
給料半分あげますと 先生の給料の半分
常識でしょうに そこで王が先生の給料半分あげると言ったところに
この人は腹が立ったんですね
なんで俺に給料半分ですかと
能力は同じでしょうと
私も先生知ってるものは全部知ってるんだと
それなのに何で給料半分ですかと
ったら 王様もあんまり機嫌がいいわけじゃないし
そんなこと言ったらあんた弟子でしょうと
弟子ったってもうちゃんと才能があるかないか探してから給料決めるんではないかと言って
自分の先生にチャレンジ
これ インド文化ではもう恐ろしいことなんです
いわゆる先生っていうのは
もう神様 自分の両親よりすごい尊い
先生は全面的に面倒見てくれるんだから
自分の子供のように愛情を持って育てるんだから
先生に向かうチャレンジっていうことは何の意味もないんです
しないんです 例えば たまに見えますよ
例えば先生が来て 音楽の世界でもね
もうピアノやらピアノじゃなくて
シタールが弾けないんです
指がもう震えたりして
それでも弟子たちが演奏するんです
その時でも先生を連れてきて
みんなすごく尊敬して
もうそこに座らせてもらって
頭を下げて先生に礼をして
失礼いたしますという感じで自分で演奏するんです
先生はもしかすると指もこうやって動きに震えながら
年取って それでも尊い方っていうのは尊敬する文化なんです
だから これでこの人はいきなりもう先生にチャレンジしたんだから
王様どうしようもなくて
じゃあ二人で競争しなさいと言ったら
この菩薩が すごく悲しくなってね
両親母親に言われたんだから教えたんだけど
最初からもう教えたくなかったと
性格が良くないんだと
それにしたっても なんで私は自分の弟子と競争しなくちゃいけないんですかと
こんなに世の中っていうのはね
醜いんです 行って森の中に入って自殺しようと
まあ先生弟子に負けたということは
自分の仕事柄は良くないんだと
で また帰って自分の弟子と競争することもいけないんだと
自分がそれた人だから倒すわけにはいきませんでしょうに
だからこう言うんですね
私にはその人と競争もできないし
競争して負けるわけにもいけないし
その人に勝つわけにもいきませんし
ましてどうせ正当とね
競争することさえもけしからんだと
先生と だから選択ないんですね
自殺するしか 逃げるわけにもいきません
他の国に そういうのはもう怒りで自殺じゃなくても
他の道がないと 正しい道
だから一番残っている正しい道は
みんな守るために自分が自殺することなんですね
自殺することに決めると
でも仏教のストーリーだからね
先生自殺して弟子が王様の仕事をもらったということは
もうとんでもないの話になるんだから
そこでちょっと話を変えて
そこで神様が退職先の神様が
なんで先生はそんなに悩んでるんですか？と
それはまあ こういうことでね
私は年でもあるし もう退職しなくちゃいけないし
でも退職できないんだと
あの人と競争しなくちゃいけないんだと
私は競争したくないんだと
競争して負けたっても珍しくないんだと
もう年だから でもなんでこんなことになったんですか？って言ったら
なんで先生そんな気が抜いちゃってね
もうけしからんと 先生はいつでも偉大なる人ではないかと
生きなさいと 自分のプロの世界だからね
生きなさいよ 行って競争しなさいと
私たちは応援に来ますと言って
神々は応援に来るということで
まあそこでまた競争があって
まあとにかく先生はもう抜群に勝ってしまったんです
弟子はもうむちゃくちゃ負けちゃったんです
まあで 負けて それでまあストーリーはもう神々も降りてきて踊ってあげたんだと
であって まあとにかくまあ
そのストーリーはこの仏教のストーリーで
この教育のこともちょっとポイントを言ってるんですね
技術を身につくことよりは
大事なのはその裏にある人を育てることだと
ですから それは菩薩の口に入れて菩薩を舞台に持ってきて言ってるんだから
それ 仏教の考え方なんです
歴史やら物理学やら化学やら
そんなものを勉強するのはただ技術訓練を受けることだけだからね
化学を受けた人間がいるんです
肩書きではないんです
必要なのは肩書きの裏にいる人間なんですね
そこは教育の世界だから
これはないんだから 我々忘れている一つは
この私たちはお互いに助け合って楽しく生きているものだと
人間っていうのは一緒にいると楽しいでしょうに
家族が一緒にいると楽しいでしょうに
家に帰ると家は暖かくて
みんなおかえりなさいって言っちゃうと楽しいでしょうに
そこで人間だから楽しいんですね
それ忘れてるんですね
競争競争だけで ですから会社に行くと楽しくないと
戦わなくちゃいけない
学校に行くと楽しくないと
なんで学校に行くと自分の家に戻るように居心地がいいところにならないんですかね
だからどこにいても人間がいるんだから
居心地が良くて楽しいという雰囲気がなんで作れないんですかね
仲良くやりましょうと
これ理解できないんですね
私には なんでそんなにお互いにギリギリなんかね
もう神経でもうなんか気に入らないし
その人なんとか嫌だなと思ったりとかね
そんな嫌な雰囲気 何で作ってるんですか？と
どこでもまあ人間楽しいと
そこは我々忘れてるんだから
まあ現代社会っていうのは一方的に精神的な病人を作るシステムになっているんです
ですから やっぱりこの慈悲の瞑想で
この生命は生命として
このいわゆる違う言葉で言えば
知識と感情 両方必要なんですね
知識だけだったら なんかすごいつまらない人間になっちゃうし
もっと感情豊かな人間になったらもっと美しいし
感情ばっかりやってたら大馬鹿者になっちゃうし
知識だけやったら全くもう機械人間になっちゃうし
ですから 知識と感情と溢れる人間になったら完全なんですね
そういうふうになることはために
この慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー瞑想が一緒になって教えているんです
だから私たちの社会でもね
そういうふうにこのまず人間だよと
生きてるものだよと だから子供が学校に勉強したくないと高校に入りたくないと思ったら
ものすごく怒って混乱して
もうもう倒れるんじゃなくて
高校に行っても行かなくたっても
人間には変わりはありませんし
死ぬまでその人間として立派に生きていられなくちゃいけないし
ですから そこら辺心配してあげればいいのに
あなたに高校を辞めてなんか楽しく生きていられる道があるんですか？とかね
どういうふうにやればあなた楽しいですか？と
そこら辺で子供だから
あんたこれはそう思っても
こういうこともありますよと
こういうところでもう引っかかりますよとかね
教えてあげれば 例えば音楽家になりたいんだと
高校に行きたくないんだと
そしたらまあ別にあなた好きだったらいいんですけど
まあ音楽の世界でもまあこういうこういうことはありますから
そこはチャレンジできますかと言ってあげれば
それだけで問題解決するんだから
子供はそこにチャレンジしたところでダメだったら
また他の道を探しちゃう
そうじゃなくて あんた音楽やるんだったら家出なさいと
出ますよと言って出るでしょうね
出たところで 東京に出たところでうまくいかなかったならば
家に戻れなくなっちゃうんですね
母親に捨てられたんだから
ですから まあ東京に出てチャレンジしたところでうまくいかないと
うまくいかない じゃあまあうちに牛もいるんだから
畑もありますからいいんじゃないか
もう帰ってきて この畑でもやったらというふうに言えるような状態に
我々は心に余裕はない
なぜ余裕がないかというと
仕事をより先に人間がいることを忘れているんですね
それさえあれば 人間は精神的に病気にならないということで
今日も用意した話はなかなかできなかったんですけど
一旦話をここら辺で終了いたします
で それからこの簡単な雑談なんですけど
この いろいろあの 皆様の質問とかはまあまとめてこちらにありますけど
この万能ケース いくつかこちらに書いてるんですね
このまあ末期がんの方で
で まだ知らせ知られていないんだと
だから奥さんの方が何か辛いんだと
だからそういう場合に
まあね  どうすることも私にもできませんだけど
やっぱり人間というのはどこまでも嘘で生きていきたいということでしょうね
がんになって末期なのに本人に言わないと
だから生まれる時騙されて生まれて
それからずっと騙しっぱなしでとか
バレちゃったらもっともうすごい嫌でしょうね
みんなに騙されたということで
やっぱりがんというのはもう宣告するべきなんですけど
くだらない考え 騙してやろうと嘘を言ってやろうというのは良くないんです
嘘にはいい悪いなんもなく
根本的に悪いんですね
だからがんになっている人にとっては
いくらショックがあっても自己観察にそれ時間がある
ですから やっぱり もう教えてあげた方がいいんですね
そうでなくて なんかこの人半年間で亡くなるんだと思って
奥さんがもうすごい親切に
前と違ってどうかどこか行きましょうとかね
温泉旅行でもしましょうとかね
やっちゃうと何か怪しいんでしょうね
そういう場合は 今まで私に悪口ばっかり言っていた人がね
なんで急に親切になったかと
だからそういうのは本当の愛情慈悲じゃないんですね
奥さんも罪滅ぼしような感じで
まあ最後の短い時間だから
やっぱり親切してあげようと
美しくないんですね そういう生き方っていうのは
まあ罪滅ぼしみたいな感じでね
まあすごい そうじゃなくて
まあ旦那が知ってる もう半年だと
で 奥さんもあんた半年間だからね
もう喧嘩しないでも仲良くやりましょうとと言った方が本当の生き方なんですね
文句言うなと 一緒に あの
なんていうか 温泉旅行でもしましょうと
元気な時は一度も連れて行かなかったんだからとかね
そう言った方が 夫にしたっても気持ちいいんです
居心地がいいんです あ
私は死ぬんだったら やっぱり死ぬ前に
やっぱりまあ親切にしてあげた方がいいと
で 奥さんは別にごく普通に自然に接することはできるんです
そのチャンスがなくなっちゃうんですよ
嘘をついちゃったら だからわざと変な格好をする必要ないんですね
わざと親切にしてあげるとかね
気持ち悪いんです ごく普通に
まあ普通にも喧嘩したならば
もうがんになって半年間のうち
何にしたって それでも喧嘩したいとか喧嘩したりとかね
で 親切にしてあげればよろしいことでね
で 死ぬのは別に珍しくはないんだから
まあもうそれはそんなに気にする必要はないし
あのちょっと 2,000万円で人は自殺するぐらいのものだから
それぐらい命って軽いもんなんですね
ですから やっぱり大事なのはね
みんなと一緒に生きて
みんなと一緒にいて 良かったと
楽しかったと この愛情の気持ちで死なれる場合
それを作ってあげる あげてください
そういう方々は で 急にがんが見つかったという人々っていうのは
やっぱりずっと性格がね
悪い 悪いし 体をいじめていましたし
ですから 例えば僕たちは 45歳ぐらいのケースも書いてますけどね
45歳ぐらい 僕より年下なんですけどね
私もがんかどうか分かりませんけども
いかない もしかするとがんがあるかもしれませんしね
ですから それは早く知った方が
まあなんとかね できないわけでもないし
ですから やっぱり自分の生き方を見直すと
攻撃的に来るんじゃなくて
放っておくんだとね 自然に
体も心もね がんが成長して早く死ぬんだったらどうそうと
で がんが消えてしまうんだったら
それでもまあそれでもどうそうと
そういうことで この食べたいものを食べるんじゃなくて
体に必要なものを食べて
酒飲みたいんだから飲むんじゃなくて
自分が本当に酒飲んで楽しいかどうか
それで気持ちいいかどうか見て
と そういうのはもうやめて
自然 あの まあ自然と生命はね
大事に愛情を持って考えるようになると
かなり治る見込みがあるんですね
45といえば もうかなりまた半分残ってるんだから
人生はね そういう人々はやっぱり生き方はもう 180度変えて
自然のままで生きていれば
がんのことではもう死なないと思います
で もう一つのこれはいい質問だと思いますけどね
あの 結核で入院していて
あの 私のような人にもヴィパッサナー瞑想できるかという
まあだから自分がもう病気で入院しているんだから
瞑想なんかできっこはないんだと
やっぱり だからって瞑想をやめるわけやめる言い訳にはならないんですね
病気になってもやった方がいいでしょ
それで心も体も治りますからね
病気治ってからやりますと思ったら
その前に死んじゃったらどうするんですか
ですから この一番瞑想する人々にとっては
病気になって まあ一家しょうに病院なんかに入院しちゃったらもうどうしようもできないし
それはチャンスだと思って瞑想した方がいいんですね
瞑想っていうのは座って足を組んでやらなくてもよろしいし
ですからもうチャンスなんですね
食事は持ってくるわ 他の面倒を見てもらうわ
もう自分でもう困らなくてもいいし
掃除洗濯あったっても
家の人々は来てやってくれるし
だからえらい贅沢なんですね
この入院なんかしていると
だからもうすごい贅沢できるとこ時ですから
やっぱり瞑想した方がよろしいと思います
このアトピーやら喘息やら
そういうこの薬に依存する病気がある場合はどうしますかとね
まあこれ病気の言葉で心のこと 1つもないんですけど
リストでは お医者さんじゃないんだから
今日は病気なんです 今日は病気です
前回が心で 今日は病気なんですよ
そうだったらお医者さんに講演頼んで
で あの そういうアトピーとかね
まあ喘息とかね なんか生まれつきついてるふうな病気もありますね
これは遺伝的にとかね
そういうのは この我々のこの
まあ精神的に治る方法っていうのは難しいんだけど
それはもしわかったならば治れるんです
あの それはもうこのカルマで言うならば
この過去世にも原因があるんですね
大体過去生でこの生命を大事にしなかったとかね
生命をいじめたとかね
人はもう散々悩まされたとかね
そういうふうなカルマがついちゃうと
もう喘息とか 自分で生きることで悩むと
呼吸することでずっと悩まなくちゃいけないということになるんです
ですから そういうふうに
この生まれつきもうどうしようもない人々が
もう いろいろ徳を積まなくちゃいけないんです
徳を積むということは
やっぱりこの自分が苦労しながらでも
他の人々の面倒を見てあげる
老人の面倒を見てあげる
この寝たきりのね 老人たちとか
そういうとこ行って できるだけボランティアでもしてあげるとかね
で 寝たきりになってて
巻き爪 状態になってるよね
いろいろ患者さんがいるんだったら
そういうところで資格取ってでも
自分の方で面倒見ると
結構自分も病気だからきついんだけど
そうしなきゃ自分のカルマは消えません
大体一人二人ぐらいの病院病人の面倒見ちゃうと
もうすぐ消える可能性あるんです
で 生命は生命を助けて楽にしてあげなきゃ
自分の生命も楽にならないんですね
だから自分が今苦しいということは
自分が楽に生きていられないということだから
じゃあ他の人に 他の生命に楽にしてあげることをしましょうと
そうすると自分も楽になるんです
アトピーとかっていうのは
この自然がね 自分に攻撃することでしょ
まあ科学的な説明違いますけど
やっぱり体が敵だと思っちゃうんですね
いろいろ食べ物とかね
例えば花粉症にも花粉にしたっても
体が敵が入ったんだと
だから自然は敵になってるんですね
そこで見えるでしょ 体が自分だけ孤立して
他のものは敵だと思っちゃうこと
だから慈悲がない気持ちなんですね
だから過去生でも慈悲がなかったんですね
だからそういう人々はやっぱりとことん慈悲の瞑想してみると
慈悲の瞑想して まあそれは体を気をつけると治る可能性あります
でもだからといって このこの仏教や宗教的な何かお祈りしてもらってとかね
お経をあげてもらって病気が治るとか
そういう奇跡的なことは思ってはいけないんです
とんでもない欲なんですね
楽に病気治してもらおうではないかとか
それで日本で宗教問題あるでしょうに
新興宗教とか病気治してあげるととかね
あんなインチキで仏教でやってあげない
やってあげる能力はあるんです
それはすぐに計算して
この人の病気治してあげるかないかということは計算して
別にケチつけるわけじゃないんです
そういうのはものすごい欲なんですね
でお経をあげてもらって
病気治してもらいたいんだと
そうじゃなくて ちゃんとバランスを取ってね
例えばアトピーの人が慈悲の瞑想をしながら
できるだけの生命を大事にしていながら生きる生きると同時に
自分もちゃんとその体に悪い環境を離れて
もう花粉症だったらね
マスクでもかけて それなりに薬でもいくらか飲んでバランスを取ってやらなくちゃいけない
そうするとどんどん薬の方が控えていっちゃうし
それから完全に治ってきますし
で 奇跡的に治って欲しいというならば
誰かの宗教団体に行って頼んでください
あの繊細さんも取られるかもしれませんし
仏教ではこの知恵が発達する見込みがあると
この人は 1日2日でも生き延びちゃったら
人生でやらなくちゃいけない
この心を育てることはなんとかするんだとわかったら
仏法僧の力を与えてあげる
そうでないと意味がないんで
どうせ死ぬんだからね
1ヶ月間生かしてあげましたと
その 1ヶ月間の命を延ばしてあげたところで
1ヶ月間で自分の心を直すことは大事にするんだったら
まあいいんですけど まあだからそれは奇跡だと私は思います
私はこの自分の国で この死にかけている人々にね
我々お経をあげるために行きますけどもね
やっぱりみんなのところに行かないんだけど
やっぱりそれなりに仏教に興味ある
本当に心を清らかにすることにすごい気持ちがある人は我々を呼ぶんですね
読んだらこちらでも知ってるし
この人は死ぬ 死ぬ準備したいんだと
死ぬ前に準備したいし
その前にしっかりとお教えを聞いて
残り時間しっかりと物事を観察して
瞑想でもして亡くなりたいんですね
それだとすぐ気持ち通じちゃうし
もうもうそろそろ死にそう
そろそろ死にそうと言ったっても
もうお経をあげて即身成仏で帰ったら
もう大体 1週間  1ヶ月間がまあ延びちゃうんですね
そこでまたしっかり意識に戻って
もうちゃんと知識あって亡くなれるようになっちゃうんですね
ですから その場合は このカルマの働きで
その人は立派なことをするんだと
1週間の命ということですから
人生一度もいいことをしてない人々の人生はね
もう最後に 1週間延ばしてあげたっても
その 1週間で何かやるということはないんだからね
欲と怒りと高慢と嫉妬
そればっかりで戦いばっかりでやって生きてきて
まあ私は病気だし もう何とかしてちょうだいと
というのは ちょっとまあ諸仏教では合理的だからね
そんなことはちょっと難しいんですけど
この高血圧の方のこともやっぱり高血圧の場合はこの心 2つの原因もありますけどね
やっぱり食べ物が悪くて体が硬くなってるんだったらね
まあそれは食べ物やらね
そういうことで直さなくちゃいけないし
あの元々心質でもね 神経質でも高血圧的な生活をしているならばね
瞑想するしか方法ないんですね
大体呼吸瞑想で治る 治るんですね
呼吸瞑想するんです あの時間かかりますけどね
半年間ぐらいやらなきゃ
で 徐々に治るんですね
だから この その治る程度を見ながら薬もコントロールした方がいいんですね
そこで薬いなくても 1週間
2週間大丈夫だなとわかってくるところで来てくるし
で 呼吸瞑想ってのはやっぱりこの自然な呼吸と一緒に自分の意識をずっと持っていって
持っていって どんどんどんどんリラックスするんですね
自然な呼吸と一緒に自分の意識を持って
集中力を意識を持っていくんですね
体全体に で どんどん持っていくと
すごく観察能力が鋭くなってきて
この血液の流れと心臓の振動を自分で感じ始めちゃうんですね
で 心臓の振動を感じ始めたら
そこをじっと見ながら
またさらに集中するんです
で それで正しく自然に動くようになってくるんです
まあ大体それぐらいのものなんですけどね
でもここで喋ってもいい一つまたありますね
あの課長に昇進しましたけど
やっぱり自信がなくなって
ストレスからね 体の体調が悪くなったんだと
で だから医師は精神的な問題だと言っていて
自分がすごく調子が悪いんだと
だから質問はもう仕事を変えた方がいいのでしょうかと
私が言いたいのは 仕事を変わらないでくださいと
課長になったところで自信がなくなって
本当に今体すごい壊れている状態なんですね
もう大人だからね ちょっとチャレンジしてみたらどうですか？仕事変わらない方がいいともいう一つの意見
なぜかで仕事を変わって
もう他の仕事に行くということは逃げることなんですね
逃げると逃げて一時期いいかもしれませんだけど
なんか悔しくなるんですね
後で で ですから その気持ちだったら変わらない方がいい
どうしても課長になったところであの仕事をやりたくないんだと
なんでそんな仕事をやらなくちゃいけないと
それだったら辞めるのは素晴らしいんですね
ああ 嫌な仕事から逃げたんだという充実感だけ生まれてくる
で もう 1つ問題は なんで課長になったんですかと
その方がね 課長になりたくなければしてあげないでしょうね
試験受かって試験受けて
なんで試験受けたんです
そんなバカなもんだ  そういうことですね
だから自分でなりたくてなったという事実は否定できませんよ
ですから 自分でなりたいという気持ちがあったんですね
とにかく で その気持ちが悪かったんですね
なんかすごいことだと
これは夢だと これやればすごいというふうな
このなんかちょっとしたガキっぽいというかね
子供持ってるような ちょっとした夢の感覚があって
それで試験っていうのは難しいことじゃないんだからね
でも合格したかもしれませんしね
ですから そこら辺は問題ですと
とにかく一番簡単に言いたい言葉はこういうことなんですね
で せっかく課長になったんだから
何のことなく 前と同じく普通にいればいいんです
そんなに難しくないと思います
全く普通に 前ほど今までの仕事のような感じでやればいいんで
だったら昇格すればするほど仕事楽でしょうに
事実は 難しいのは下っ端の人々なんだ
全部ゴミをやらなくちゃいけないんだから
それから課長っていうのは他の人々を管理することだから
この高慢がないと 俺が課長だからどう
そんな感じじゃなくて
その人のことに愛情を持って
あの なんとかね こういうことをやってくれませんかとかね
やってくれなきゃ ちょっと褒めてあげてでもね
いろいろみんなと仲良くしてね
慈悲の気持ちでやれば何の問題もないと思いますね
だから難しくないしね
そんな仕事っていうのはね
どうせ同じ仕事をする現場で物だからね
環境は知ってるし だからこの自信なくなるということは
ついになんか自分突然偉くなったと思っちゃうんですね
あれは心壊れちゃうんですね
あれも高慢でしょ 高慢というか自我でしょ
あれ 私は偉くなったんではないかと
それで自信が消えちゃうんです
別にどうってことないんだと
いつでも言ってるでしょうに
課長へ出せたから まあどうったことはない
毎日の同じことだからという感じなんですね
落ち着いている人だったら
まあ机が変わるだけでしょうとかね
毎日と同じことやと あ
私は偉くなったと それから家はもっと大きい家に住まなくちゃいけないんだと
なんか庭付きの家に住まなくちゃいけないんだと
この車ではダメですよとかね
仕事を全部辞めた方がいいんで
そういう気持ちになるんだったら
仕事変えるとこじゃなくても
それだったらまあどうったことないんだと
アパートに住んでいたならば
まあアパートでもいいんだと
奥さんが言うかも もうアパート生活はダメですよと
別にいいんじゃないかと
そこでいろいろ人がお客さんが来ると
アパートでダメだったら
まあまあお客さん来るんだから
面倒くさいんだから ちょっと大きいと広いところに行きましょうというふうな感じで
自然でいいのに ちょっと心に入っちゃうんですね
あれ 自分が偉くなったんだと
これから偉い 偉い人の振る舞いと言うんですか
それしなくちゃいけないんだと
これできないんですよ
急に舞台に乗ってやろうと思ったっても
だから演技しないことなんですね
だからこの問題は一番すごくいい問題だと思いますけど
ずっと言っていたんだから
ちょっとしたことでことで心がもう壊れちゃいますね
偉くなったんじゃないんだと
別に と すごく普通だと思えばいいし
昨日聞いた話なんですけど
ハワード大学に入って
この修士号に入ることできましたと
で 聞いて みんな喜んで
もう大変 勉強家の科学者の人で
次の日は警察 警察から電話がかかってきたみたいですね
そしたらまあ 分裂するようになっちゃって
どうしようもないんですね
まあせっかく だからいろんなおかしいことを言ってるんだと
あれも同じ現象なんですね
ずーっと勉強して 徹底的にもう科学を勉強して
大学も出て まあすごい立派な国際レベルで研究をしようではないかと思って
自分の成績を全部出して
向こう側からまあ受け入れたんですね
受け入れた瞬間で あれ
自分が国際的なレベルの科学者になったんではないかということを
偉くなったんではないかと聞いちゃって
その状態に自分に対応できないんですね
頭の妄想世界だから それでもう自信がなくなっちゃって
じゃあ分裂病で逃げようと
心は無意識的に分裂病を作っちゃうんです
かわいそうですけども
何のことないんですよ
そんなことは ハーバード大学に行ったっても
もう日本の大学とまた同じことで
自分の同じ慣れてる研究室でしょうに
ただ あちらの連中は英語を喋るだけのことです
それはもう科学者にとって英語っていうのは何のこともないし
別に言語は問題ないんだから
ですから このたとえノーベル賞を取ったとしても
ノーベル賞を取った学者にとってはそんなに大したことないし
ノーベル賞を取ったでしょう
だからどうしようかと
この賞を受けるためにスウェーデンに行かなくちゃいけないし
王様に会わな そんなことを考えちゃう
自信がなくなるだけで
そうでないと毎日の人生とは何の変わりもないんですね
だから ほんのわずかなことで見てください
ハーバードまでね 入学というところじゃなくて
研究員としてね 受け入れた人は
次の日は分裂になると言ったならば
ほんのちょっと自分が偉くなったんだと思った瞬間で
この偉い状態に自分には対応できない
頭で作った偉さだからね
で 心が壊れる ですから
課長であろうがもう社長になろうが
気にしないこと なぜですかというと
今日会社に入った人は次の日社長になれませんでしょ
もし昨日会社に行って
全部仕事終わって帰って
次の日はあ あなた社長ですよと言ったら驚きますけどね
それだったら手も足も出どうすればいいかわからないし
どんな会社かまだ把握もしていないし
そんなことないんだから
すごく仕事をして仕事をして全部できたところで
もうほとんど係長のことを全部できたところで係長になるんだから
昨日とほとんど同じなんですね
課長の仕事はもうなんだかんだできるようになったところで課長になるんだから
本人にとっては面白くもないんです
なるべきことになっただけのことだから
たとえ会社に社長になったとしたっても
それをそこら辺で社長と毎日一緒にいろんな仕事をして仕事をして
社長のことをずっと助けてあげたところで
社長が辞めたら自分が社長になることだから
面白くも別に何のこともないんです
そんなことは でも ちらっと頭に入っちゃったら
あ 明日からは偉いんだと
それ人生終わってしまっちゃうんですね
覚えておいてください
心というのはそういうちょっとしたことで壊れてしまっちゃうもんなんです
ですから いつでもそういったことを失敗したって構いません
成功してもそれでも構いませんと
という生き方は正しいと
大体まあ質問はこここれぐらいですね
じゃあ終わります どうもありがとうございました
ありがとうございます